psychological observation discovers no
law for the relation of
self-consciousness to actuality or to
the world over against it and through
the mutual and difference of both it is
forced to fall back on the peculiar
determinate pneus of real individuality
which exists in and for itself or
contains the antithesis of being for
itself and being in itself if faced with
it within its own absolute mediation
individuality has now become the object
for observation or the object to which
observation now turns
with paragraph 309 we now enter a new
section of the phenomenology it's a
section within a section within a
section we could talk about all sorts of
subsections we're looking at reason with
a sort of capital R and we're in the
subsection observing reason and now
we're in the third part of that
observation of self-consciousness in its
immediate actuality that's vir Clea kite
and Hagel appends to this the names of
two disciplines physiognomies and
phrenology now these are two as we call
them today and as they were actually
calling them back that as well
pseudo-sciences these are disciplines
that present themselves as giving us
something that's based in observation of
reality and which which is supposed to
tell us about the phenomenon in this
case the the body right then that
reveals to us the truth the
intelligibility of the phenomenon but in
reality it turns out that these are just
fortuitously connected and in a way
pseudo-sciences are worse than no
scientific pretensions at all because
they stand in the way of genuine
scientific progress certainly scientific
not only in the sense that we use it
today with our arm you know conception
of the scientific attitude and
scientific method and the massive
research projects that we have going on
and the influx of technology but also in
the sense of this in shaft the way that
Hagel conceives of it where the human
subject understands its own position its
own involvement in the scientific
enterprise itself so what's happening
here in this very short section where
we're not going to get anywhere near
physiognomies right at the start we're
picking up where the last one left off
we we tried
derive general laws that would allow us
to understand the the relationship
between individuals or the individual as
sort of a category and then larger scope
things you know these laws that were
supposed to be logical laws or
psychological laws and it turned out
that there were all sorts of problems
that arose and they arose precisely
because of the type of matter that we
are trying to study that is individuals
now you know we can study individuals
within societies or cultures but there's
always a lot of variants and it's not
just random variants it's you might say
intentional variants Hagel talked in the
previous sections about the the person
who's supposed to be governed by these
laws or these these conditions are
determined in this way having something
almost like a choice or at the very
least a say let's call it and whether
they would allow those things apply to
them and to what degree and in what ways
and they reinterpret them so it's not a
pure passivity that we would you know
perhaps like to have and that we imagine
or we project to humankind rather
humankind takes into effect that takes
into account the effects that the the
determination is supposed to have on it
now here we're seeing the aftermath of
that and Hagel talks about psychological
observation psychological observation
was aiming to find some sort of law or
laws that would govern the relationship
between self-consciousness on the one
side and actuality vehicle a kite what
what is what we're confronted with or if
you like the world and he describes this
he says the
here we go the world over against it
right the world that's supposed to be
determining it and what happened is
funny we didn't get these laws why not
because these exist in a relation as he
says of mutual indifference towards each
other so what does observation do it
tries to go further to grapple with the
the part that was so recalcitrant to
formation of laws real individuality and
Hegel uses a real here as the adjective
so he says why it's falling back on the
peculiar determinate pneus of real
individuality which exists in and for
itself right what it is to be a living
human being to exist in and for yourself
also for others also you know you're in
itself is a way of being for others and
we can talk about that in a bit it says
it contains the antithesis of being for
itself and being in itself if faced with
in its own absolute mediation so there's
this activity that's going on within any
real individuality within any individual
that you might run into on the street on
the bus interacting with it through the
internet probably doesn't matter so much
about you know what particular medium
that we're talking about here and he
goes on he says individuality has now
become the object for observation or
this is a very important turning point
the object to which observation now
turns so what we're going to be looking
at through the rest of this long section
is how and we're going to try a number
of different house and that should lead
us to the question whether we can
actually find something like raw like
regularities that we can then apply to
individuals and we're going to be
looking here's
giving away a bit of it we're going to
be looking at the physicality the
Corporal reality the bottle eNOS of the
individual why are we going to do that
well you know that's really the thing
that we get to encounter you know now
you're not seeing me bodily by my
standing in front of you or hearing the
sound waves themselves going through the
air that my in a whole vocal apparatus
is producing Hagel's also going to talk
a lot about hands right you notice I do
a lot of gesturing but this is what you
get to see this is what you're presented
with when it comes to other people you
can't directly open up somebody's head
and suddenly see their soul or their
guys there's spirit their mind so the
question that we're going to be faced
with is well what is the meaning of the
body and how is it related to the soul
or the mind or the spirit whatever it is
that you want to talk about in the
individual is there any sort of system
or or discipline or is some sort of neck
that can open things up for us and make
things clear or do those turn out to be
inherently problematic and just sort of
weigh stations along the path that we're
going to traverse
the individual exists in and for himself
he is for himself or is a free activity
but he has also an intrinsic being or
has an original determinate being of his
own a determinant nests which it is in
principle the same as what psychology
thought to find outside of him in his
own self therefore there emerges the
antithesis this duality of being the
movement of consciousness and the fixed
being of an appearing actuality in
actuality which in the individual is
immediately his own this being the body
of the specific individuality is the
latter's original aspect that aspect in
the making of which it is not itself
played a part but since the individual
is at the same time only what he has
done his body is also the expression of
himself which he has himself produced it
is at the same time a sign which has not
remained an immediate fact but something
through which the individual only makes
known what he really is when he sets his
original nature to work
here in paragraph 310 were beginning to
study in a reflective and in a
phenomenological way seeing whether that
can yield us a scientific this inshaa
felica way of understanding the nature
of the individual and that that is
really going to mean understanding the
nature of the individual as body as life
in in Germany as opposed to another word
for body Cooper which could have been
used but this has you know the
connotation of being the lived body the
body that works that still is a
functioning being not just meet on a
slap and Hagel is going to draw a number
of well it's not a number of antithesis
because it's really the same things that
are being opposed to each other in this
this gagan Zots the antithesis as miller
is translating it but there's two sides
here so he says the individual exists in
and for himself now notice that this is
in and for himself is getting split into
two sides pretty familiar move by this
point for those who followed Hagel up to
the this this point isn't it and he says
he is for himself right there's a for
itself side and then there's the in
itself which Miller has translated here
as intrinsic being the German is just on
Zeke so in itself is fine when you
compare it with the the for Zeke the for
itself and let's actually go a little
bit out of order here just to mix it up
a bit so he talks about the side of the
in itself and he says that the
individual has what he calls an original
determinate being of its own so what
does that mean well he says a
determinate pneus which is in principle
the same as what psychology thought to
find outside of him so this determinate
being of its own is not being found
outside of it where is it being found
you might say within its skin within the
boundaries of the the body right so your
body is not something that you have
absolute control over and I don't mean
just in the sense of you know can you
raise your arm or not raise your arm
okay you can raise your arm now will
yourself to stop breathing for five
minutes you can't do that Hagel's not
just concerned about the present he's
concerned about well where did this body
that you've got come from why is it the
way that it is and in many respects we
can say that we are responsible at the
very least or even to be praised or
blamed for the condition of our bodies
you know I should lose some weight right
that presumes that I actually have a
choice about losing weight and that
things that I do could you know
positively or negatively affect my
progress towards that goal that either I
embrace or that I grudgingly in a go for
you know the doctor tells me you need to
lose weight if I want exercise right I
can make my body into a certain type a
good example of this you know you
wouldn't you guess it necessarily by
looking at me right now but in my you
know teens and 20s I was actually very
athletic and I engage in a lot of what
was called endurance lifting at the time
which was using weights and doing very
long routines with many sets many
repetitions medium amount of weight
rather than trying to max out anything
and what was good about that is it left
me a frame that I could rely upon for
quite some time that's something I did
to my body right and we could talk about
all sorts of other things as well you
know damaged parts of my my limbs while
I was in the Army and didn't get it
taken care of you know
just all sorts of other things whether
we lower our selves to get enough sleep
or not or whether we're looking at
screens late at night those things
affect our body they make our body to
some degree what it is but there's a lot
of things that we don't actually have
control over and they don't fall within
the scope of our activity there's
something that is given to us right I
was going to end up being tall whether I
chose to or not and and I can certainly
do things that as we say would stunt
your growth and I could you know affect
my posture so I hunched down like that
as opposed to standing up straight but I
was not going to be a short person
likewise you know I can dye my hair if I
like to but I am this is the hair color
that I've got it now it's changed a
little bit because there's some white
and some gray in it a lot more on my
beard but you know you get what you've
got right you can put contact lenses in
change green eyes to brown or two purple
or black if you want whatever you like
but so far as we're talking about the
original inheritance of the body we've
got something that is an original or
spring the determinate being of our own
and it talks about this as the fixed
being of appearing actuality that's a
very nice phrase right the body does
appear it comes on the scene and it is
an actuality it is a vehicle e kind it
is something that we are confronted with
get up in the morning and you find your
you're in your body it's not as if you
got out of it during the night and
walked around you know the way that
people do in cartoons you are your body
and this is a lesson that as you get
older it gets driven homes you know more
and more because you know you may not be
entirely happy with the course that your
body is taking now on the other side we
have the for itself what he calls the
free activity the ton right the doing
and
this he talks about in terms of a
movement of consciousness now this is
also part of what it is to be a living
being to have a body to exist in time
and space with other beings like us in
the world all these sorts of things that
we can talk about we we have agency
shooting this video right now great
example if I smoke that's up to me if I
don't smoke that's also up to me maybe I
come from a culture of smokers or maybe
I have genes that predispose me to take
more pleasure in that than other people
you know those are all things that would
be situational and these two things are
in an interplay Hagel talks about them
as being in a gang and zots and
antithesis but we should really see this
as an opposition that is dynamic these
things interact with each other he goes
on and he says so there's being the body
of the specific individuality is the
latter's original aspect that aspect in
the making of which it is not played
apart like I said you get the body you
got and it grows in the ways that it
does and your environment affects it and
some of us you know locked out in
certain ways and some of us got the
short end of the stick in other ways but
you know there's there's a lot of things
that we don't have control over when it
comes to our body it's part of why the
Stoics would say body is something you
don't actually have within your power
but he said since the individual is at
the same time only what he has done his
body is also the expression of himself
which he has himself produced our bodies
are at least to a certain extent the
product of our doing the product of our
choices the product of our habits our
commitments so he goes on he says it is
at the same time a sign which has not
remained an immediate fact but something
through which the individual only makes
known what he really is when he sets his
original
nature tour so the individual gets an
original nature and then sets it to work
does something with it in acts things
and this goes back and forth and back
and forth throughout the course of a
life I should point out one thing here
which is that when Hagel uses the term
sign in general Hagel views signs as
conventional as not really showing us
what the thing itself is but it's
something sort of standing in the place
of her in the way of the the thing that
we want to understand all that said what
we've got here is the body as the locus
for all of this the body is is that
through which we come to grasp the
individual including the individual that
we are
if we consider the moments here before
us in relation to the previous view we
have here a general human shape or at
least the general character of a climate
a continent the people just as
previously we have the same general
customs and culture in addition there
are the particular circumstances in
situation within the general sphere of
actuality here this particular actuality
is present as a particular formation of
the shape of the individual on the other
side just as previously the free
activity of the individual was made
explicit as also the fact of his own
actuality in the face of the actuality
already given here the shape stands for
the expression of his own actualization
established by the individual himself
the lineaments and forms of his
spontaneously active via but the actual
ax t both general in particular which
observation previously found given
outside of the individual is here the
actuate of the individual his inherited
body and it is precisely in this that
the expression originating from his
activity appears from the psychological
point of view actuality in and for
itself and the specific individuality
we're supposed to be brought into
relation to one another here however the
whole specific individuality is the
object of observation and each side of
the antithesis is itself the whole to
the other to the outer whole therefore
belongings not only the original being
the inherited body but equally the
formation of the body resulting from the
activity of the inner being the body is
the unity of the unshaped end of the
shaped being and is the individuals
actuality permeated by his being for
self this whole which contains within at
these specific original fixed parts and
the lineaments arising solely from the
activity is and this being is the
expression of the inner being of the
individual posited as consciousness and
movement this inner being is to no
longer a formal spontaneous activity
devoid of content or indeterminate and
activity whose content indeterminate
as before was the case lay in external
circumstances on the contrary it is an
extrinsic ly determined original
character whose form is merely the
activity we have them to consider here
how to determine the relation between
these two sides and what is to be
understood by this expression of the
inner in the outer
paragraph 311 is fairly long and there's
quite a number of things mentioned in it
but the main features of that I think of
what I've got here on the board really
in the second half of the paragraph so
let's see where Hagel starts he begins
with the comparison he says if we
consider the moments here before it's in
relation to the previous view that is
the view in the previous section we have
here a general human shape or at least
the general character of a climate a
continent two people just as previously
we have the same general customs and
culture the the externalities the
circumstances that were supposed to be
determining the individual human being
according to psychological laws that
we're going to more or less make them
all behave the same way in similar
circumstances right and we saw that that
wasn't the case so he says in addition
there's particular circumstances and
situations within the general sphere of
actuality okay so what might that be
well you know I happen to be a professor
or a speaker or a cabinetmaker I'm born
in a certain family you know we can go
on and on right so he says here this
particular actuality is present as a
particular form of formation of the
shape of the individual on the other
side just as the free activity activity
of the individuals made explicit and the
fact of his own actuality the face of
the actuality already given here's the
the important transition here the shape
stands for the expression of his own
actualization established by the
individual himself through his own
activity so if we want to think in terms
of the previous section what the
previous section talked about was the
freedom from being determined the
freedom of choosing how it would be
determined that kind of undated a strong
sense of determination on the part of
the end of
jewel in relation to the universal here
we're talking less about that less about
the freedom aspect and more about how
the individual himself or herself is in
fact determining him or herself by their
reactions by their choices by their own
doings so he goes on and he says here
the shape stands for the expression of
his own actualization established by the
individual himself the lineaments and
forms of his spontaneously active being
sounds very dynamic at this point that
he says but the actuality who which
observation previously found given
outside of the individual in the
circumstances right and what was
external to him it now finds here in the
actuality of the individual his
inherited body the body that he gets the
body that by the way is never really you
know the same thing for a moment to
moment to moment to moment right because
you could say you inherited your body
when did you inherit it when you were a
little baby right or even before that in
the womb but you're not that anymore
right you're your cells have changed you
are now probably if you're watching this
a grown person unless you're something a
very precocious kid and even then give
it another ten years you'll have an
adult body so he goes on and he says
it's precisely in this that the
expression originating from his activity
appears so we're looking for again a
relationship then we've seen before
write a law of the inner somehow
expressing itself in the outer and what
is the inner in in this case well we
might say that there's actually more
than one inner as we find out in this
passage we saw that too in the previous
section two sections ago right there was
the inner of the outer the outer of the
inner we can go on and on so he goes on
and he says
the actuality general in particular
which observation previously found the
ott is the actuality the inherited body
from the psychological point of view
actuality in and for itself and the
specific individuality we're supposed to
be brought into relation to what what is
that so when we were engaging in
psychology in the previous section
trying to deduce these laws we wanted to
find some way to connect the actuality
the way the way things are the vehicle
Ian kite right well there really with
the individual without compromising the
individuality of the individual not just
their uniqueness but their capacity for
self determination for self formation
for taking a stance upon themselves even
if it only in an implicit way those are
difficult things to reconcile aren't
they it's not quite so straightforward
but that's what indeed Hagel has been
aiming at throughout this this whole
section of reason so he goes on and he
says here the whole specific
individuality is the object of
observation now observing reason is
going to focus on the individual as
individual the individual is wiggled out
of the psychological laws that were
supposed to determine them fine we'll
look at the individual him or herself
how is that going to work says on each
side each side of the antithesis is
itself the whole the outer is the whole
of the individual the inner is also the
whole of the individual now
mathematically that seems to be a bit of
a problem right because we've got what
half half each half is one but we're not
doing mathematics here we're doing
conceptual dialectics or phenomenology
we're trying to make sense out of how it
is that the individual is seated in the
body which we're not going to fully get
it
this point but that's going to be worked
with over the course of this section and
that there's an inner and an outer
manifestation or aspect or however you
want to put it really there's going to
be more than one inner here too by the
way that we should point out so he says
to the outer hole therefore it belongs
not only the original being that is the
inherited body but equally the formation
of the body so this here is which
appears to be more inner is actually
also part of the outer right the
formation oops formation of the body by
the activity of the inner being so what
are we talking about their you notice
I've got some other arrows drawn and
there's reasons for that here in this so
the outer is taken by the inner what do
we mean by the inner here well the
individual as he says posited as
consciousness and movement the activity
the ton of the last paragraph that doing
right so the outer body is something
that is available you might say for the
consciousness for the aspect of movement
that the consciousness is able to get
this is really talking about the
relationship between the soul and the
body but in a very different way as
Johnny malik recognized in this this
section now what happens with that is
the individual forms their body by their
activity by the activity of the inner
being how is the inner still in ER if
its external izing itself in the other
this is a problem that we're going to
see dela with but it's also one that
we've already seen played with in the
previous paragraphs the previous
sections right so he goes on and he says
so to this outer hole we've got these
two parts or two aspects the activity
the inner being forms it and the body is
a unity of the unshaped and of the
shaped being and is the individuals
actualities beautiful phrase the
individuals actual either veer click I'd
permeated by his being for self if we
want to think about this in terms of the
relationship between the body and the
soul or the body and the personality the
body and the mind where exactly in your
body is your mind located oh you might
tell what's up there in the brainpan
really is that where you're conscious
let me poke you in the not just in the
eye but let me uh punch you in the
stomach and see whether you're conscious
down there at all we don't have to get
quite so extreme with it but you get
what we're saying consciousness is
something that permeates the living body
this is something by the way that
Marilyn Ponte maurice merleau-ponty at
twentieth century phenomenologist who
drew i would say almost equally upon
hagel as you did her Cyril really was
quite attentive to and that's going to
be something that's coming out of the
reflections in this section so he says
this inner being or this this whole
which contains within itself the
specific original fixed parts of the
lineaments arising solely from the
activity is and as being is the
expression of the inner being of the
individual positive is consciousness and
movement that's what the inner being is
this inner being is to no longer a
formal spontaneous activity this is very
important devoid of content or
indeterminate there is determinacy there
this is what allows us to have some sort
of connection that's not quite yet well
established between what else is in ER
which is what Hagel is going to call the
original character of the person but
here's what's going on expression is
taking place from the inner expressing
itself in the outer and all of these
aspects are
involved with in the living human body
of the individual so he goes on and he
says the inner being is on the contrary
an intrinsically determined original
character whose form is merely the
activity so now we're posed with a
problem that's what he ends this
paragraph with we have them to consider
here how to determine the relation
between these two sides and what is to
be understood by this expression of the
inner in the outer it's not yet clear
it's it's one of those catch phrases
right the outer expresses the inner okay
what does that actually mean that's
where we're going in the paragraphs yet
to come